Elbert what's up Hi Sam can you hear me
yes I can hear you uh just for
transparency I'm not a Christian however
I am well I'm reading the Bible and I I
have more knowledge and I'm I'm gaining
an interest in it so that's more than
nothing at least all right yeah um your
question was do they act independently
no what verses did I give you you said
John 519 I heard John 5 what 19 and then
John
5:30 John 8:28 to 29 right okay John 12
49-
50 John 1612 to 13 shows the father's
Holy Spirit never act independently but
always in perfect and separable Union
I'll show you some of the verses that
was your first question you asked me do
the do they act independently no they
always work in perfect and separable
Union here it is John
5:19 here it is let me show you the
first one John 5:19 Jesus said to them
truly truly I say to you the son can do
nothing of his own accord but only what
he sees the father doing for whatever he
does that the son does likewise so I
only do what the father does and I do it
the same way the father does it that's
John 5:19 now few more references so I
can Hammer this point down let me line
them up for you one second all right so
that you can see it from the Lord's holy
mouth his blessed holy consecrated mouth
our Lord okay one second let me just get
it here all all right here it is and
that's true of Father Son and Holy
Spirit here John
5:30 John 5:30 I can do nothing on my
own authority as I here I judge and my
Gentlemen Just because I seek not my own
will but the will of him who sent me say
I only work in perfect and separable
Union with the Father John 8
28-29 John 8:
28-29 you go John 8
28-29 so Jesus said when you have lifted
up the son of man then you'll know that
I am he and that I do nothing on my own
authority but speak thus as the father
taught me John 828 29 nothing on my own
30 but speak thus as the father taught
me and he who sent me is with me why he
has not left me alone for I always do
what is pleasing to him always 24 hours
a day every second every minute of the
hour seven days a week okay that's John
8282 29 now John 1249 to 50 two more so
then you can follow up with any other
question John 12:49 to 15 for I have not
spoken on my own authority the father
who sent me has himself given me a
commandment what to say and what to
speak I know that his commandment is
eternal life what I say therefore I say
as the father has bidden me and then
finally about the Holy Spirit okay John
12-13 John 161
12-13 there you go there we go I have
yet many things to say to you but you
cannot bear them now when the spirit of
truth comes he will guide you into all
Truth for he will not speak on his own
authority but whatever he hears meaning
from the father and son he will speak
and will declare to you things that are
to come so there you go the Bible's
clear they do not act independently
always in perfect and separable
Union okay I'm following I hear um
Christians say in the will of the father
through the son in the Holy Spirit they
speak of it in this sort of fashion so
in the beginning of Genesis When God
says let there be light do you
understand that as all three speaking
simultaneously
no because in Genesis 126 the one
Speaking is addressing the other members
of the
godhead let us make man in our image and
our likeness
I see okay okay then then I'll I'll
follow up and read those citations more
care yeah but yeah coming back to what
you said the will of the father through
the Son and the Holy Spirit yes the will
of the father through the
son okay well depending on what the
context is because you just took you
took that sentence out of context
meaning I don't know what the context is
the will of the father through the Son
and the Holy Spirit well what was the
context of it what came before so I can
know what they're saying exactly when
someone says the will of father through
the son meaning the father's
will that you seek to do will only be
done with the father's approval in Union
with Christ meaning you cannot do God's
will apart from trusting in Jesus Christ
Our Lord so if you're a Muslim and you
think you're doing God's will you're not
doing God's will because the will of God
is to believe in a son the Lord Jesus
Christ and listen to him Mark 9:7
Matthew 17 verse five so when it says
the will of the father through the Son
and the spirit you need the Holy Spirit
to empower you to carry out the father's
will a will that will only be pleasing
to the father if it's done for the sake
of the Lord Jesus Christ this why I need
to know the context of that
statement um this is something in my
memory I don't have a specific link or
citation to give you but but thank you
anyway um so now when you say who's
speaking well when the father speaks in
Acts the Son and the Spirit are acting
with the father but he's the father for
the reason because he has Authority and
he's the
initiator right for example in 1
Corinthians 86 it says creation is from
the one God the Father through the Lord
Jesus Christ meaning the father is the
one who
initiates right he Wills that there'll
be a creation but the Son and the spirit
are in perfect Inseparable Union with
the father so what he desires they
desire what he Wills they will but he
would be the initi initiator right
yeah I've heard similar things okay that
that's clear um so if I can move on to
the second question it's okay this is
regarding um the last supper and I know
Catholics use the term
transubstantiation
to the elements are changed into another
substance but the appearance Remains the
Same yeah I have some difficulty with
this concept because okay you can have
want God's mind is not your mind yeah so
when I in my plain just Layman
understanding what for the last supper I
take that event in context with Jesus
saying I'll rebuild this temple in three
days implying his body he is 22 but
that's not the last supper right yeah
but I'm kind of trying to paint a
picture in my head of what he's saying
because he talks he doesn't talk in one
sentences right it's kind of more of a a
grand message and then he says all food
is clean like there's no Halal Haram
kind of thing so yeah that's Mis
misinterpreting Mark 79 you you're
bringing in too many passages that
you're not understanding and you're
misinterpreting because what's the point
though so I can get to the point because
that was Mark 719 and that's the
translation you gave is not necessarily
the correct one because he's not talking
about foods are clean but that the foods
you eat are purged because it goes out
of your stomach either as feces or urine
yesk 19 the passage it talks about Foods
being made clean in Romans 14:20 but
then that too has a caveat which is too
complicated not really relevant to the
Eucharist but what's the question about
the Eucharist uh so I interpret the Last
Supper as Jesus including his disciples
you just said you're not a Believer
right pardon you're not a Believer yet
right uh some things I struggle with
definitely but you're not a believe
right you're not you haven't given
yourself fully to Christ right yes yes
okay see now this is where it's
dangerous when you say I interpret well
you haven't spent enough time in the
scriptures to study
to even have a valid interpretation
because the Bible in the hands of
someone untrained is a dangerous weapon
it's like putting a gun or machete or
sword in the hand of a 5-year-old so
your interpretation really doesn't carry
any weight because you may not be
qualified in fact you're not qualified
to know what it means okay good but I'm
just bringing that in context you
understand what I'm trying to show you
right yeah yeah for sure okay but go
ahead I just wanted to clarify I'm not
cutting you up to be rude I'm just
trying to show you look at the look at
the implication I interpret that's why
we ended up with 40,000 denominations or
40,000 branches of Christianity but go
ahead okay um what what the what I
thought okay as I read it was Jesus was
essentially when he said my body is the
temple he's giving his body uh
ceremonially to his disciples so he's
including them in his uh Kingdom
essentially his Temple and giving them
Authority Eucharist is the sacrifice of
the Passover and he saying that now the
Passover is divine by My Sacrifice not
the
lamb he is the sacrificial
lamb of a new Passover of a new Exodus
of a New Covenant because what was the
occasion it was the Passover the
slaughtering of the Passover Lambs to
commemorate God redeeming Israel out of
bondage to Pharaoh Egyptian slavery it
was the slang of an actual lamb an
actual lamb being sacrificed whose meat
they had to eat not break any of the
bones this you'll find in Exodus 12
outlined and articulated and then they
would take the blood mix it with bitter
herbs and hisa put it on the top and the
sides of the door and when God would see
the blood then the firstborn of the
house would be spared but the firstborn
of all the Egyptians from their children
to the cattle would be killed which led
to an great cry and then forced the
pharaoh to let them go it was an actual
actual sacrifice so Jesus is now saying
that this Passover is now defined by My
Sacrifice because he is the Passover
Lamb who takes away the sin of the world
John 1 129 1 Corinthians 5:7 that has
nothing to do with the disciples because
he's now redefining the Passover in
respect to his sacrifice on the cross
cross okay I see I wasn't taking the Old
Testament context into it okay well
that's the context right because it's
the Passover luke4 16 how he said I
eagerly desire desire to eat this
Passover with you